we are gonna start by making our cookies
are you gonna be a good helper yeah
mommy okay
we're gonna make cookies let's let's
make cookies again
brace yourself because kylie jenner just
posted
a new youtube video baking in the
kitchen with her daughter stormy
and it's over the freaking top cute
oh no and now they've got me inhaling
cookies too
thanks ladies thank you in the video the
mommy daughter
duo rocks festive matching pjs while
they decorate some halloween cookies
you are such a good helper storm
and literally no one on this planet is
more pumped than the two-year-old
are you excited
you were the best typewoman storm yeah
or hype baby
[Music]
i did it whoa
i love how excited you are about the
cookies are you ready to decorate them
how cute of course baking with a little
one
messes are to be expected
oh you're cleaning oh we're cleaning but
kylie wasn't that tidy either and stormy
made sure to let her know
what happened mom we made a little mess
so messy so messy can you even handle
the cuteness
i mean stormy really is her famous
mama's mini-me she even
sounds like her okay
i love making cookies with you mommy
of course the kylie cosmetics founder
shares stormy with rapper travis scott
and while their little girl was all
smiles for the cookie tutorial
i love you back in september kylie
shared
this behind-the-scenes clip of the crew
trying to get a family photo
and let's just say stormy wasn't having
it
okay
back to those cookies oh yeah so
easy we have our cute little girls
stormy revealed what she's being for
halloween
what are you going to be for halloween
storm a pumpkin
no what's your real costume
a minion you're going to be the purple
minion and me and daddy are going to be
the
yellow minions and remember when kylie
did the candy challenge with stormy
and she showed some serious restraint
let me go to the bathroom
and then you can have it okay okay
you're gonna wait for mommy yeah
yeah she gave us an encore of that cute
little song
and to put the cherry on top of all that
cuteness
stormy proved she loves to share
especially with her cousins
who should we give these cookies to
true bye okay that was such a good outro
baby
peace out camera
you